use these semi-circles and a semi-circle
semi means semi means half so use these
half circles to make a circle so if you
take two halves of a circle if you put
them together just right you're going to
make a circle so how do we do that
well this first choice right over here
these are no longer the semi-circles
these are each a third of a circle so
we're not going to this isn't and this
doesn't even complete the entire circle
so that didn't make a circle
this one they took the two semicircles
but they didn't make them so that their
outsides completely line up with each
other so this isn't a circle
but this one they took the two
semi-circles and they put them together
just right so now their outsides line up
and we have a full circle so that's our
choice
and we got it right let's keep doing
this use these small triangles to make a
big triangle
all right well here they use them to
make not a triangle but this looks like
a parallelogram a quadrilateral
here they've used the two triangles and
they've made a triangle because this
whole thing has three sides one
two three
here they use those two triangles to
make a square but we want to make a big
triangle so this is our choice
let's do a few more of these
use these semi-circles to make a circle
well here they're not meeting on the
flat side so this isn't this isn't a
circle this just looks like something
else like two smiles or something two
pieces of a blue watermelon slice on top
of a purple one
this is a circle so that they put the
two semi-circles in the right way and
here they didn't even make the meat so
this would be our choice
use these small rectangles to make a big
rectangle
well here they didn't line them up right
to make a big rectangle here they did
this whole thing has one two three four
sides
so i'll click that one this one doesn't
look like a rectangle looks like some
type of an l or something so i'm not
going to select that one
and we got it right